[Music]
[Applause]
joe thomas you can follow him on twitter
at joe thomas 73 nfl network analyst
former browns all pro offensive tackle
now working for the nfl network joe
thanks for joining us if you're a browns
fan how do you feel today
i think you feel great and they should
feel great because going into this
season everybody wanted to tell them
about how great they were and you always
worry about you know stubbing your toe
in that first game i know they didn't
win but they beat kansas city in that
game if you watch it from start to
finish and it's just a matter for them
now of just learning how to finish down
the stretch this is a team that turned
the entire uh organization and franchise
around when kevin stefanski got there
the mentality has completely changed the
culture has changed now just learning
how to win down the stretch but i mean
having the chiefs who
two years ago they won the super bowl
last year they were in the super bowl a
lot of people thought that they probably
could have won that super bowl and going
into their place in week one and really
outplaying them i don't think that uh
that is anybody's uh
something that anybody should be ashamed
of if you're a browns fan but we're
waiting for a signature moment from
baker mayfield
is that fair to say we're still waiting
for that moment where you go okay that's
what elite quarterbacks do
yeah absolutely and you know last year
against the ravens he had that moment
but unfortunately the mar jackson was a
little bit better down the stretch um
and they were they weren't able to win
the game so you don't really think of
baker having that signature moment but
he's still such a young quarterback if
he continues to play the way he did
yesterday the rest of the season he's
going to get plenty of those moments in
this season right now he's ready for it
what was more disappointing for the fan
bases the bills losing at home to the
steelers or the packers losing the way
they lost to the saints in florida
uh the packers obviously because
everybody's talking about the last dance
for the packers aaron rodgers devonte
adams like this is their moment they're
going to win the super bowl expectations
are sky high and to be able to go and
just completely a turd against a team
that really how so many questions going
into this game you know
how are they going to replace drew brees
how are they going to be able to focus
on this game with the hurricane
displacing so many of them and their
family playing the game in jacksonville
and then coming out and stomping all
over the packers really in a defensive
effort i know jameis winston had five
touchdown passes but it was that defense
that completely stifled the packers and
turned aaron rogers into a common
looking quarterback that was really
impressive and a lot of credit has to go
to sean payton in the job he's done with
getting that team ready focusing through
all the distractions and making jameis
winston uh from a turnover machine to a
touchdown machine
but also there does the defense usually
start out ahead of offenses in in in
your opinion and what you experienced
when you played
yeah they do because they don't have as
many things to learn they don't have as
many things to install it's much more
instinctual um as far as just
learning how to go out and tackle and
run and hit like there's a lot of plays
on defense don't get me wrong but
offense is so much more about detail
communication
installing new plays reacting to what
the defense is doing to you so typically
development-wise the defense is way
ahead but when you have a guy like aaron
rodgers who's been around forever and
they've been in this offense now several
years under matt lafleur uh i don't
think that necessarily is true in this
case they should have been able to come
out
and they should have been firing on all
cylinders it's not like this is the
first time that they've played in this
offense and it's not like this is aaron
rodgers fifth or sixth year in the nfl i
mean he's seen everything that's out
there he's got an experienced offense
there's no excuse to have a clunker like
they did on sunday
is chandler jones a hall of famer
i don't think he has hall of fame
credentials yet like if he retired
tomorrow but certainly the way he played
the game on sunday he's got hall of fame
talent and he's building that hall of
fame resume um to be an all-pro to be a
pro bowler you can do that in one season
to be a hall of famer you got to do that
over nearly almost a decade uh of
football and so he's got 102 sacks right
i think
certainly there's
the number right right that's a big
number but without the longevity i think
he becomes one of those guys that you
talk about but i don't think gets in at
this point but certainly he's right
there i mean a few more seasons like
he's been having and i think he
definitely can be a hall of famer
what's the most sacks you gave up in the
game
uh i don't think i've ever given up a
sack damn it it was always the
quarterback's fault
no i remember there was a game um where
i gave up two sacks um
like sort of the middle part of my
career against the falcons and i was
really frustrated by it but you know as
an offensive lineman we're always
telling ourselves well you know the
quarterback was in the wrong spot he
held onto the ball too long and so um it
really wasn't my fault yeah they're
going to give me the credit i'll take
the credit yeah it was my fault but you
always got to talk your way out of it
like a you know a high school kid well i
was late for curfew but uh you know i
hit a cat on the way home and just had
to find the owner of the cat and then
you know you always make those excuses
in your head did you ever yell to get
mad at a quarterback because he might
have cost you a sack because he held
onto the ball too long or didn't step up
in the pocket yes uh i yelled in my head
and typically instead of yelling at him
directly because i know that's kind of
unproductive what i would do is i just
wouldn't help him up like you know
usually if if you see the quarterback
laying on the ground it's a lineman's
culture to go right over help your ball
carrier up help your quarterback up
especially if you gave up the sack like
wait wait what was the name of that
quarterback
i can't remember i can't even remember
all the quarterbacks that i played with
that started with me but that was
definitely played with a lot of
quarterbacks quarterbacks back there
there was a lot of quarterbacks back
there but i definitely instead of
helping him up i would just turn my head
and walk right back to the huddle that
was his way of knowing that i was very
displeased with what he did on that play
what game surprised you the most
yesterday
it was the packers right because living
in wisconsin
i mean everybody had high expectations
that was what the conversation was about
the entire offseason how this was their
last dance they were going to win the
super bowl aaron rodgers was super
motivated he finally you know kind of
got a little bit what he wants so he's a
little bit more happy but maybe what we
want from an aaron rodgers is a pissed
off aaron rodgers maybe that's what he
needs to get the best out of himself and
to get the best out of his teammates
because
what we saw of aaron rodgers was not
what i recognized as an aaron rodgers
performance
when you have a rookie quarterback
uh what's that like for the offensive
linemen of knowing what your job is or
how does that job change when you have a
rookie quarterback
well it makes your job a lot harder
because like i mentioned i don't think
i've ever given up a sack because the
quarterback was in the wrong spot uh on
every single one of those sacks but
that's the issue with a rookie
quarterback and we saw a little bit with
trevor lawrence this weekend right
they're either not in the right spot
because they dropped too deep their
footwork wasn't right um or they're
holding onto the ball too long they're
not going through the progressions the
right way and so you deal with all those
things as rookies because they got so
much on their play the quarterback
position has the most to learn out of
any position in the nfl by far and it's
so much of it is decision making getting
the football out on time and so a lot of
times when they're thinking about what's
the coverage doing what's the pressure
do i need to change the protection they
forget about some of the little details
that okay maybe i'm supposed to take
five steps and not seven if i hit my my
seventh step i need to step up and i
need to hitch up because otherwise i'm
gonna be standing at ten and a half
yards and the line is blocking for a
spot at nine yards and so as alignment's
the worst feeling in the world where
your guy turns and runs up field and you
turn and you feel like you're running
him by and all of a sudden out of the
corner of my left eye i can see the
quarterback and he's standing not where
he's supposed to be and i'm like oh crap
i gotta turn the jets on to try to push
this guy past but at that point it's
already too late so it's just part of
dealing with uh a rookie a young
quarterback is dealing with those
moments where oh he didn't do what he
was supposed to but that's sort of the
cost of doing business with the rookie
if you're blocking for ben
roethlisberger or you're blocking for
somebody who has some mobility like the
difference in you know because buffalo
didn't get to ben roethlisberger
yesterday and he's not moving he's not
running outrunning anybody
um you know the different philosophy
that you have when you have somebody who
has some uh
elusive
moves there as opposed to a stationary
yeah when you have a quarterback that's
elusive like a russell wilson josh allen
those guys patrick mahomes
you know you can't have that internal
clock where okay i know the ball is
supposed to be thrown i gotta turn and
run and chase the football and try to
get down field in case there's a fumble
or in case i need to peel a guy off the
pile what you're doing much more now is
you're reacting to whatever your
defensive player is doing it's a little
bit like when you're playing defensive
back and main coverage and you're
following your guy you're watching his
eyes because you can't see the football
you can't see what's going on behind you
same thing as an offensive tackle i'm
watching that defensive end and i'm
queuing off of his eyes as soon as his
eyes go this way boom i gotta chase him
because there's a good chance that all
of a sudden russell wilson has extended
the play and he's running out of pocket
and i got to do whatever i can by hooker
by crook to get my head in front of this
guy and get one last shove to be able to
give russell that half a second then he
needs to go hit tyler lock it down the
field for that big play so um it's much
different than you got a ben
roethlisberger you've got those older
quarterbacks who are much more this is
where i'm going to be they're going to
be right where they're supposed to be
and once your guy turns and runs
downfield you know the ball has been
delivered it's not like ben's scrambling
back there trying to make plays with his
feet when you have that college coach
successful coach who goes into the nfl
urban meyer
what's the what's the wrong thing for
that college coach to do once he gets to
an nfl locker room
the one wrong thing i think we're seeing
a lot of the wrong things and a lot of
the difficulties from urban honestly i
think the hardest thing for urban meyer
is that he had no nfl experience and so
the hardest thing then is hiring your
staff and there were some whispers
coming out this week already that there
was a lot of friction between the guys
that he brought in from college that he
was comfortable with that he had a
relationship with that he wasn't going
to have to teach every single thing that
he wanted to those guys and the guys
that he brought in that had the nfl
experience because it is a different
culture in the nfl and in college there
is a lot of different concepts and
schemes and how you want to run your
practice how you need to treat your
players like a little bit more like
professionals like men to get the most
out of them and so i think the learning
curve is already really steep when
you're a coach that spent most of the
time in college and you make that
transition to the pro game we've seen it
so many times but it's even worse when
you have no nfl experience because
typically you're putting together a
staff that has half the guys that are
like your guys and then half the guys
that are nfl guys that you don't really
know but that have been recommended for
you that you've hired
without really having any relationship
with and there's going to be a lot of
friction there there's going to be
friction between the guys that were
college coaches that are trying to coach
the nfl players like they're still in
college where it's more about trying to
motivate them in a lot of different ways
to get them to play hard whereas in the
nfl a lot of those guys are
self-motivated and they're motivated by
money they're motivated by feeding their
family they're motivated because they
could get cut at any moment and so i
think it's a lot more about teaching at
the nfl game and versus in colleges
about motivating and developing and just
teaching the values and the fundamentals
of football hard work
toughness
being on time that doesn't really fly as
much in the nfl
you can see joe thomas nfl network's nfl
game day kickoff thursday at 6 eastern
ahead of the giants washington game on
thursday night football do you think ron
rivera brings in cam newton
that's a great question i i didn't hear
um what the injury situation to the big
beard man is i know he hurt his hip but
i'm not sure how long he's out i still
like fitzpatrick with that team because
that defense is so good i thought heidi
played pretty well yesterday um and at
this point it's difficult to bring in a
quarterback have him learn the entire
offense and get on the same page with
your pass catchers um unless you're
going to bring in cam and say hey use
your legs we want you to scramble and
you know kind of change the offense a
little bit more it's more rpo type stuff
quarterback power doing some of the
things that he did in new england then
maybe you think about it but i think if
they're going to keep the same offense
and continue to just try to throw the
football then i don't think it's a great
fit
good to talk to you as always joe we'll
be watching on thursday night thank you
buddy awesome thanks dan that's joe
thomas nfl network analyst former browns
all pro offensive tackle and we'll end
up in canton in the hall of fame